قال رئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان بلاده
لن تتراجع اطلاقا عن استكمال انشاء الشريط
الامني على عمق 30 كم على طول حدودها
الجنوبيه واضاف اردوغان ان بلاده لم تعد
تركيا القديمه التي يتم ترجيعها حسب
تعبيره
[تصفيق]
م وتسبون في الكوارث ويشمون حروبا
بالوكاله يعرضون ايضا امن حدود تركيا
وحمايه حياه مواطنيها همهم ليس اهل هذه
الجغرافيا ولا اصولهم العراقيه وانما
مصالحهم السياسيه والاقتصاديه والتنظيمات
الارهابيه التي يرعونها سنقوم حتما
باستكمال الشريط الامني على عمق 30 كلم
على طول حدودنا الجنوبيه والهجمات التي
تقوم بها التنظيمات والارهابيه ومن يدعمها
لن تنجح في حملنا على التراجع يعني الامر
في تركيا اليوم ليست تركيه القديمه ليست
تركيه التي تضرب على راسها ويتم تركيعها